saviez vous que votre télé était
radioactives
[Musique]
on est aux états unis dans les années 40
aeio beaucoup de méfiance envers les
rayonnements que peuvent produire un
téléviseur mais va falloir attendre la
généralisation des téléviseurs couleur
quelques cette anxiété lors commence à
être généralisée pire encore en 1967 une
étude sort disant que le téléviseur
couleur émettrait des rayons x qui sont
au dessus d'un niveau qui souhaitaient
et là c'est la peint en 1968 l'année
suivante donc la peur commence à gagner
tout le monde et bientôt le congrès
américain va convoquer les représentants
de l'industrie la télévision pour
s'expliquer et tous vont mener à une
réglementation mais y'en a qui vont plus
loin on va commencer à faire des
recherches et plus spécifiquement des
représentants de la santé publique se
rendent compte que les fameux
rayonnement baisser ou négligeable mais
on va quand même dire aux gens par
manière préventive un recul et vous un
peu de votre téléviseur et ça va suffire
il ya quand même un élément de contexte
qui est très important dans les années
60 aux etats unis
la peur de la guerre nucléaire on entend
parler de nucléaire partout et plus
encore on se dit que ça peut arriver
chez nous dans nos téléviseurs
donc on commence à parler de télé
radioactives ont dit ça y est notre télé
devient une arme nucléaire
[Musique]
tout ça n'est pas nécessairement
rationnelle mais ça fait partie d'un
ensemble de croyances qui perdure
jusqu'à aujourd'hui
d'où la raison pour laquelle on dit
souvent à nos enfants mais même à nous
mêmes de ne pas être trop près du
téléviseur
tout ça à cause d'une étude qui nous a
un peu induit en erreur
[Musique]